draft week continues we're here in the
barn for an episode of pft pm and
joining us now a guy who will not have
to wait very long on thursday night to
hear his name called chase young joins
us on behalf of old spice which is
donating 320 000 to the united way on
chase's behalf along with all of the
rookies from all 32 nfl teams to help
young players begin their charitable
efforts as they join the league fans can
make contributions of their own during
the nfl's three-day draft-a-thon virtual
fundraiser by visiting nfl.com slash
relief here he is
chase young just turned 21 years old the
other day happy birthday chase how are
you i'm good how are you thanks for
having me
hey it's great to see you again it's
great to talk to you i remember seeing
it at the scouting combine and we said
before we got started it really does
feel like it was a long time ago it
wasn't that long ago but the world has
changed how do you celebrate your 21st
birthday during a pandemic where
everybody's staying at home
i know it sounds it sounds bad but i
i just had to tell
the brother in the house with you know
just my immediate my immediate family um
i really couldn't do too much um so we
just really just chill in the house and
you know um i enjoyed my family so
um it was all cool just being with my
family i was my birthday
well it's great you were able to do that
hopefully soon we'll be able to go out
and you'll be able to go out and
celebrate it properly when the world
gets back to normal and hopefully that
happens sooner rather than later
how have you adjusted to the way the
world has been the past six weeks i know
it's one thing for me i'm old i don't
leave the house anyway but when i was
your age i wanted to go out on one and
do things how hard has it been for you
to adjust to being at home all the time
yes uh you know um
i guess
uh you could go out but uh
it's nothing's open so it's nothing to
do
you know what i'm saying it's like you
could go out but it's nothing open so
it's nothing to do so
um i mean only only times i really leave
the house
is to work out
um
you know right now we're trying to stay
as uh healthy as possible
um well we're trying to stay on our
piece of cue
cues with you know having like
uh hand sanitizer um washing our hands
um
you know just everything in regards to
just
um staying healthy and uh just trying to
um you know ultimately survive you know
through this pandemic that we got going
on
and chases fans of the sport we're all
anxious to see football players on the
field again how anxious are you to get
on the field and start chasing
quarterbacks again yeah you know i'm
real anxious you know um you know just
coming out of college
um usually spring ball
would be we'll be here now um so that's
definitely a springboard you know you
get back on the field um
and uh you know you can get back to it a
little bit and you get back in the
feeling uh but you know now the next
level is no spring ball so
um i feel like you really have to take
uh you know off season workouts
um you know you got to turn them up
another notch and
uh you know that's what uh you know i've
been trying to do but right now i feel
real comfortable what i'm doing
and uh i feel
um
comfortable enough that um i'm gonna put
my best foot forward when that time
comes well we all know that you're going
to be able to do that one guy who's sold
on what you can do is urban meyer one of
your former coaches at ohio state he
recently said god put that guy together
he said i'm going to make one of the
best defensive ends to ever play college
football how do you react when you hear
your former coach praise you that way
oh man it's uh
you know as a young guy coming in him
standing on me you know it
didn't start like that there was a lot
of uh you know
um growing up i had to do
uh you know
just you know the freshman struck was
you know when you come in um you know
coach meyer he was
he was that coach that would always keep
it real with me um sometimes i would
even ask him for his evaluation on
certain things that i do
and you know you would give me that real
and uh you know i would take it
and go and use it as motivation to you
know work even harder
and um you know he always wanted me to
be the best
he always wanted me to be able to um
dominate the game
um and you know
now that you know i have i'm done my
career um
you know i can i can look back at it and
say uh
you know i achieved some of the things
that uh you know he thought i could do
so it makes me feel real good
and from from your own perspective chase
how much of what you're able to do
is god-given ability versus you having
determination and hard work and drive
and
and an effort to get the absolute most
out of your god-given abilities
yeah i think uh
you know my god you got god-given
ability was a
it was a lot of my sophomore year but i
feel like my junior year the biggest
switch was technique uh
the the biggest reason i might have
dominated the game was because my
technique
um that i really just focused on that
off season
um after my sophomore year
and i told myself the only thing i was
going to do was a technique that uh you
know coach johnson teaches
and um you know basically i i did my
best to try to perfect it
um
you know obviously i wasn't perfect but
uh you know my my best was was still
pretty good so i'm happy about that
what was it specifically about your
technique that you changed last year to
hit the higher level yeah just uh hands
on
my hands on pass rush um that was
that was um you know definitely a
big a big key
key point for me um when i headed into
the off season uh my my get off i wanted
my get off to be faster
my first step out of my stance uh in my
hips and also um
playing with my eyes
um
you know um
my iq for the game has won the
um
drastically um you know between my
sophomore
and uh junior year um you know just the
way i would watch you know um the way
um you know play recognition on the
field that's that's that's that's that's
a big point for me from i would say
because i feel like a lot of my
production um
came because i i knew
you know a lot of times it was a pass
before the ball even snapped um like
during the wisconsin game i think
through the first game where um you know
i had like four sacks
uh two of the sacks um they said it was
when we watched the film every time 37
was in the backfield it was 90 page
so every time he lined up as a runner
back in the backfield
um
you know i was putting my ears back
getting off the ball
um
so just little things like that man um
he'll help me to be the player um you
know that i was the season
chase one thing i noticed watching your
film sometimes you're in a three-point
stance sometimes you put the second hand
on the ground
when do you decide how do you decide
whether you're going to go with both
hands down or just one hand down for
your get off
yeah so a lot of times if you see both
hands down um if i'm on the right side
so basically my hand so my hand is to
the balls down the hand
um that's not to the ball it touches the
ground but i'm not really using it it's
just there this is you know on the
ground just because uh
my arms are long so
um i don't want to you know put it back
i want to let it flow and uh you know
just let it relax so you know when the
play is ready you know it's all really
there um to engage a man in front of me
so i would have sat in a full-point
stance it's usually just a three-point
stance or or i would stand up and uh a
lot of times they let me choose um
you know when i wanted to stand up
and when you get to the quarterback it
all happens so damn fast when you're in
the moment does anything go through your
brain i mean it's like a cobra strike it
happens so quickly do you have any
conscious thought while you're in the
pursuit of the quarterback
that's like everything uh
everything slows down you know
um
the closer you get um
but uh this
you know it's crazy once you
that feeling that uh you have
when you do get a sack uh
you know it's something uh special
that um you know can't be matched
um i love seeing i love seeing a pass
rusher in number two you know they're
not gonna let you wear number two at the
next level what number do you want to
wear at the nfl level
you know um i'm still thinking about
that uh
i don't know i haven't uh
that hasn't been a real
hasn't been a real big thought of mine i
think right now
but uh you know when the time comes and
you know i gotta pick a number two i
gotta have some some numbers so but
whatever number that may be
um i guess that's that's number you're
gonna see
you know all the experts think that it's
gonna be joe burrow to the bengals at
one and chase young to washington at
number two
would you put a percentage chance on
that phone ringing on the bengals
looking at the film a little bit harder
watching what you do
how you get off the ball looking at what
nick bosa did last year and listen to
all the people who's saying you may be
even better than nick bosa is there a
percentage chance in your mind that the
phone's going to ring and it's going to
be the bengals not washington taking you
first overall
yeah so um
you know i
i probably thought about every situation
that could happen uh
but you know i feel like at the end of
the day
it's not in our heads it's in god's
hands so um that's you know that's when
i think about that that's when i just
sit back
um not even worrying who might draft me
um and you know just let everything
happen on the song man because
you know
um okay i'm not gonna sit here and keep
wearing or keep thinking this keep
thinking that
um and you know get myself browed up so
i'm just gonna let everything happen
and uh you know whatever god's plan is
that's that's that's really easy one for
me
well i can see you got the awesome
multiplies t-shirt on i got one up at
the house you're you fill it out a
little bit better than i do
what are you going to be wearing on
draft night
okay so with my whole draft uh my draft
um if it was still in vegas gucci was
supposed to do my suit
um and it's actually
it's ready but it said in italy right
now
um so we're still going to see if we can
get that here um
but if not i'm gonna wear uh i'm gonna
wear clothes
um by a designer called john elliott
um
based out of california um
so
um i have uh you know i'm gonna have the
fits
um you know for for uh
for the draft so if my suit doesn't come
in and i just wear giant
well we look forward to seeing it and we
know it's going to happen early the
floor is two the ceiling is won his name
will be called within the first half
hour at the latest on thursday night
chase it's great seeing you we
appreciate everything you've done on the
football field we can't wait to see what
you do at the nfl level all the best
this week thank you i appreciate it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports